we're still waiting to see scarlett
johansson's black widow in her own movie
it now is supposed to come out july 9
fingers crossed
but yesterday howard stern got the dirt
from emily blunt on why she didn't take
the role
that was introduced in iron man 2 back
in 2010.
you were offered the role of black widow
in the marvel series
yeah and that's a great role for uh
scarlett johansson but that would have
been a great role for you too and
a slam dunk big role
but you had to turn it down because
you're so busy that you were doing
gulliver's travels at that point no no
no i i actually do want to clean up the
story on colors travels i was
contracted to do gutters travels i
didn't want to do gullibus travels
i am a big fan of fantastic four you've
heard the rumors
that you and john what do you mean don't
make a face
that you and john are going to be reed
richards
and his wife sue in the fantastic four
movie which i think would be a great
idea
no that is fan casting that and no one
has received a phone call that is all
um that's just people saying wouldn't
that be great and
and uh that's it no one has in a way are
you
too good of an actress to really
participate
are you too good of an actress to really
take that role
seriously in other words maybe that's
why you don't even react to this black
widow thing that you could have been the
black widow in iron man and that could
have been your franchise and blah blah
blah blah blah because in a way maybe
the whole genre
of superhero movies is beneath you it's
not that it's beneath me
it's not it's not that because i love
iron man i wanted to work with robert
downey jr would have been amazing
but i don't know if superheroes are for
me they're not
um they're not up my alley you don't
like the superheroes or is it that a lot
of women i speak to i think
it's been exhausted i think it's just
that we are inundated it's not
only all the movies it's the endless tv
shows as well
and it's not to say that i would never
want to play one
it would just have to be something so
cool and like a
really cool character and then i'd be
interested but
in general i don't race to see superhero
movies
i love this one comment where did it go
oh francis says
my fantastic four dreams crushed in five
seconds
we did get to see emily blunt in like i
think it's a win-win for both emily and
scarlett but yeah what do you think of
uh kisha what do you think of emily
she's probably gonna do a superior role
honestly she could have said anything
that voice
[Laughter]
into in the accent i was like girl you
could talk all day and i am
listening um no i i get it i mean when
you're that
talented and revered as an actress i
mean you don't have to do anything you
can pick your roles and you can have
your opinions about things
i would love to see her as a superhero
especially with the accent and the whole
she's just such a cool chick i would
love to see it um
but that's that's her take on it i i
think you i mean you'd have to at some
point
feel a way about not getting to be black
widow like there's got to be something
about it that
it's cool especially when you have kids
you know there's toys there's excitement
there's a lot of excitement around being
a superhero who wouldn't want to be a
superhero but
you know she is a huge actor and i don't
know how it would affect
um her brand so to speak because she
does do more serious roles it's
difficult to do serious roles and go be
a
superhero and then come back and do more
serious roles i feel like when you do
these superhero type of films
um the acting community doesn't always
um
respect it right
i think as an artist yeah i
i love i love emily blunt and this to me
is what somebody sounds like when
they're telling the truth
about the role that they did or did not
get in a superhero movie
not what andrew garfield said last week
by the way okay this is what the truth
sounds like
if you want to go and find that clip and
watch an actor poorly lie
uh but i will say this about emily blunt
and i know maybe she doesn't want to do
fantastic four and this specific genre
of superhero movies
isn't for her but if you watch edge of
tomorrow with
tom cruise and emily blunt it is an
awesome movie and she is basically a
superhero in that movie
like she kicks so much ass one of my
favorite characters
in a film in like the last 10 15 years i
loved her in that
so she's capable of doing that i just
think that there's a commitment that
comes with being in a marvel or dc
film and that's probably probably the
thing that dissuade her is that
you don't tend to look at it as a role
edge of tomorrow was a role it was a
great movie
these movies tend to become your life
and
i don't know how appealing that part of
that job is
to somebody like emily blunt because i
think what you said keisha is uh and i
agree with you which is that she's able
to do
all of these other things and not be
looked at as
one role as soon as you become iron man
there's people who will only see you as
iron man regardless of what robert
downey jr
ever does ever again and he was awesome
yeah
and who knows in terms of schedule i
mean maybe it all would have worked out
but yeah maybe emily couldn't have done
cecaro maybe she couldn't have done
it tomorrow maybe she couldn't have done
into the woods like we've seen emily do
these great varied roles so
and granted scarlett johansson has done
some great roles along the way too but
like
while she's doing a black widow but yeah
i think it worked out for the best for
both of them that they
yeah like they both got through great
roles and scarlet's done a great job
with black widow
also and can i just say that i watch
gulliver's travels for the very first
time two nights ago and it breaks my
heart to hear her say that she didn't
want to do that movie
and that she only knew because you're
attracted obligated
i feel so dirty like i feel like somehow
i betrayed emily blunt
by even watching him i like hearing that
movie
yeah thank you violated like i do i feel
like i heard her
also also i'll point out i'm just seeing
it on screen because i'm sure
we called out for it i type up those
questions i misspelt her last name says
emily bunt
i apologize now that i missed the l
somehow wow
wow okay
yeah see we both let her down today